it's already girl Stegosaurus no how
many was very sell baby no no no you
know like it's different now I figured
while I don't have on some of the makeup
from shooting episodes of this might get
today am i compounding anxiety about
creating content lately hasn't fully
talked me out of doing this I may as
well sit down and make a stream of
consciousness video with you issues
became this might get that's a place you
can get regular content Monday through
Friday my friend made my heart and I
make funny videos over there link in the
description box below
already plugging and haven't even got 30
seconds into this video okay what are we
talking about I have stuff to plug but I
will I'll just stare at the socket for a
little bit and talk about some other
contents and eventually will get happy
post fourth of July what did you guys do
wow that sounds dangerous boring thank
you I went to the East Coast I went to
Boston and I got to see my brother my
younger brother Timmy I remember him
from such video says speaking of hiding
we're going to talk about gays in
science yeah he got out the video game
and lives just a very nice quaint life
in Boston and oh you did it right I
think no we're here it's fine look at
this box it minute it's fine I was there
for about a week I would have to put
them in for a day and came back down to
Boston I have not spent that much time
in Boston since my brothers lived there
and it's the first time I really
realized that Boston is very cute and
very [ __ ] crazy Boston has its really
fun facade of like charm and grit and
then you get up to the charming grit and
you realize it's just Looney tune it's
just a bunch of Looney Tunes in like a
pinball machine all bouncing off of each
other and that was awesome
we came across dough made it for
characters that I couldn't believe it
constantly one on fourth of July I went
to a bar called the Tam which I know a
lot of you tweeted at me then it's a
very dumb bar but I I loved um I love
trash I love dumb trash I am dumb trash
oh here comes so it was perfect and then
we met this bartender I wish I could
remember her name but she was absolutely
perfect probably in her fifties or
sixties and she had her arm in a cast
Jess Brooks to open up a bottle of Stoli
blueberry for her to make drinks for
these other people because she couldn't
get it open by yourself already perfect
I think Brooks now is a tip but then
someone finally asked her because I
didn't have a courage to why she had a
cast on her hand and she said because I
needed new knuckles
that's that she needed new knuckles
woman with the thickest Boston accent
needed new knuckles she was punching
something she got punchy who knows maybe
I'm getting ahead of myself babies just
arthritis from punching a clock she
works so hard at punching and there was
a man at another bar we went to during
the day before going to see Jurassic
world we'll get to that later and then
at this other bar something was a little
off it was probably 2 p.m. the day after
4th of July a weekday a working day for
everyone else in Boston Brooks and I
didn't have to work from vacation kind
of sorna this man was just talking at
this bartender who was very obviously
hungover very European and they're very
obviously hungover he was barely
functioning I know what a barely
functioning hungover person looks like
immediately and that was that guy he was
just trying to do his job in a shoe bar
with hardly any people coming in and
this guy was talking to him like the
stapler guy from office space and I told
um - because they've moved my desk four
times already this year and I used to be
over by the window and I could see the
squirrels and they were married but then
they switched released I'd done I
ordered a vodka soda the soda was very
flat but I it was in no space to tell
this barely functioning hungover dude to
fix anything I give credit where credit
is due he got to work I'll suck down
some flat vodka so that I've drank worse
in my own home got myself so there's no
room to judge so he was sitting at the
bar and one of the things I overheard
him say immediately when we sat down was
you just start saying Long Island iced
teas Long Island iced teas they say one
is not enough and three years too many
that was a joke that was a joke all of
the bartender who is just trying to make
a drink and not paying any attention
the bartender's back has turned to him
but he's still talking at him and he
goes oh my howl
life if only I had a wife she would and
the bartender walked right away
just cut himself off mid-sentence and oh
my hollow life if only I had a wife she
would buy I mean I never have to hear
the end of that sentence but I can
imagine what the end of that sentence
probably is oh that was fun times and
then I went all Jurassic world in IMAX
because we spend money on things we
don't want to see but AC
air-conditioning
it had air-conditioning you guys there
may have anything there's seen it
already if you have let me know your
thoughts and the comments down below
here are my thoughts it's not great
we'll give you any spoilers but just at
one point there's a crazy night us or
that chomps through a metal spiral
staircase and then the next scene is
taking his time with this little thing
fan club like murder machine nails and
he decides instead of smashing through a
window
to just gently open it using the actual
empty candle and eat the whole metal
spiral staircase but pristine erm the
emptied window handles please what has
got some cringe to it maybe you like
that I like laughing at that kind of
thing so it wasn't the worst experience
in the world and there was just a lot of
questions also Bryce Dallas Howard can
you give a girl some tips on how in
running away from murder Bob machine
dinosaurs in rain in humidity on an
island how you keep your bags perfect
how you get them bags that way the
internet and I have been talking we have
some terrible news to tell you about
your banks there's a lot of
inconsistencies in my opinion there's so
much insane stuff happening in the world
right now but 90-day fiance can we talk
about that
Pedro hey no no no oh by the way
speaking Jurassic world Daniella Pineda
was on my podcast not too deep last week
and go listen to it not too deep calm
she's fantastic in the movie she's like
the dinosaur veterinarian she's the
second female lead to Bryce Dallas
Howard and I thought she was great
and a lot I felt like I was watching the
movie and supporting a new friend also
who listened to the podcast with her she
talks a lot about how the movie got made
and what it was like meeting Jeff
Oakland and
really a fun thing while we're deep lugs
let's get to it if you don't know I made
dog slash dog owner and jewelry not too
long ago the link is down below if you
want to check it out there are necklaces
and dog charm sets but now it's time for
oh that's right I've made cat jewelry
and cat owner charm
there's an alert to the dog sighs dog
owner terms here are the three new
styles that are available for you guys
whoa and these are the boxes that they
come in and I mentioned them online new
today and you guys seem to really love
them already so go check them out
they're 20 bucks each which i think is
great for a necklace and a pet charm the
packaging is so stupid cute I love it
and they're really great if you don't
even have cat you can get the [ __ ]
power necklace and give it as a gift BFF
[ __ ] power necklaces we need some
goddamn [ __ ] power
so the link for that is down in the
scription box below I'm so excited this
has been a long time in the works plus
we have some more jewelry coming up it's
related to BFF situation so get ready
for that scenario soon and when you do
get them when they do arrive in the mail
please tweet me photos tag you an
Instagram because I love photos of
animals that are very confused as to why
they need to be in a photo right now Oh
world cup who are you rooting for oh
that's fascinating I didn't think that
you cared about that team baby chick oh
did the World Cup what else all right
there's a quick poll show of
consciousness video for you guys if you
like these kind of videos let me know
when is this I don't know what this move
this looks like I'm trying to sit on a
hot toilet right now Oh fun have you
guys like these kind of videos let me
know and make sure that you go check out
the new cat jewelry and I gotta figure
out making videos on here more
consistently maybe I just need to get
calm for dinner again
prime confidence